so Captain America New World Order and
the Thunderbolts are some of my most
anticipated MCU movies there really
seems to be a lot of cool things coming
out of them and with the casting of
Harrison Ford as general Ross I think
the movies are going to be something
special throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down everything we
know about the films and also the plot
leaks and rumors that are currently
flowing around about them please hit the
Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the video
and if you subscribe I'll love you three
thousand by the way a huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
breakdown now for the first part of the
video I want to talk about Harrison Ford
William heard his play General Ross
since the Incredible Hulk but he passed
away in March 2022 leaving a big hole in
the Marvel Universe but yeah as we
wondered when the Red Hulk will be
showing up and it seems like Ford will
be the one who turns into him in case
you haven't read the Red Hulk run it
basically picks up after the events of
world war Hulk with Bruce and a secure
prison located underground murders
carried out by a Hulk like figure start
to happen and general Ross is also
seemingly killed by about this turns out
to be a life model decoy and red Hulk is
in fact the general now both Captain
America and the Thunderbolts movie will
be closely linked to one another with
Ross becoming the president according to
Daniel rbk the Captain America movie
will follow on from the eternals with
there being a big focus on tiermet last
left in the ocean the celestial corpse
will be excavated and those that dig on
it will apparently find adamantium this
is of course the indestructible medal
that was used to cut Wolverine's
skeleton and it's one of the most sought
after elements on the entire planet we
saw in wakanda Forever how the UN were
desperately trying to get vibranium and
France bloody France he even sent a SWAT
team in to try and get some the element
we'll kind of stop this but the rest of
the world are still desperate to get
their hands on whatever they can to make
them the new superpower and that's where
Tiamat and the Quest for adamantium
comes in according to Daniel Ross will
want to claim the adamantium so that the
US can become the most dominant force in
the world this will create a new world
order and allow them to sell the element
or use it to control others now standing
against the president of America will be
Captain America AKA Sam Wilson they've
had run-ins in the past with Ross being
the reason that they had to go into
hiding after Civil War during Infinity
War cap Sam and the rest of the group
showed up at the Avengers compound which
is when Ross told Roddy that he had to
arrest them all they all got pardons
after saving the universe but Ross seems
like the kind of guy that holds on to
grudges the Sam will apparently form a
team against him and this will include
some people that we've met in the MCU
before firstly will be working Taurus as
the Falcon and in the Falcon series we
saw him taking Sam's Wings Carl Lumley
will also be playing Isaiah Bradley and
he was of course introduced in the
Disney Plus show as well as for the
villains there are rumors that we will
be getting multiple ones appearing from
d23 we know that Tim black Nelson will
be returning as the leader and actually
have a theater
about what he's going to be doing now
the most obvious thing is that he's
trying to get the adamantium himself
however I actually think that his role
won't be connected to it and instead
he'll be how Ross turns into the Red
Hulk in the Incredible Hulk he took a
sample of Hulk's blood and is also
dripped on his head and started to
transform him She-Hulk saw the
intelligent you're attempting to get
she-hulk's DNA and in the comics he was
a member of them as well though it might
not be connected I think that the leader
might have cracked out a 10 people into
Hulks and that he will be the one who
turns Ross into the red one the US
government's been trying to crack the
super soldier serum secret for decades
and the program Banner originally
started on was about trying to replicate
this potentially the leaders being hired
by Ross to find a way to do it or even
as a way to replicate the Hulk's power I
think that Ross will then take this and
potentially the leader could end
manipulating and also controlling him
this will allow him to bring in his own
New World Order and also gain the
adamantium now along with General Ross
my time to shine hello has stayed that
live Tyler is also in talks to return as
his daughter Betty in the comic she
ended up becoming Red She-Hulk and this
transformation was carried out by the
leader this would be a great file for
She-Hulk even better than Todd if that's
even possible and I have a feeling they
might go that route if Red Hulk is
brought into the MCU as well now my time
to shine also state that Jessica Chad
stains being eyeed to play one of the
main villains as well and though it was
the arise she could play sin this has
apparently been debunked as being said
that she's playing someone big but that
it's not who you think so I think she's
playing mystique and therefore she's not
playing Mystique because it's not who I
think using the process of elimination
the only character it can possibly be is
Jean Gray even now you're thinking nah
she's not playing Jean Gray but the fact
that we all think it's not her means
that it is because it's not who we think
it is surely yeah you guys have got to
see that [ __ ] anyway Captain America
releases in May and Thunderbolt is the
next film The follower which will be
released in July for months now you've
heard that the Sentry will be in the
movie and I think it would be the
ultimate power play by Marvel to hire
Henry Cavill for this Sentry is
basically a Superman archetype and there
are rumors that he will eventually
become the villain so far the lineup's
made up of Yelena belova Bucky Red
Guardian ghost us agent and also
Taskmaster it's also rumored that
Abomination will be in the lineup too
but they've kept it a secret to not
spoil the ending of She-Hulk which was
was it really an ending kind of drop the
whole Todd mystery look moving on now
Val will be the person who's formed the
group and she will also appear in
Captain America New World Order in
apparently a smaller role she was trying
to get the vibranium as well but with
adamantium now being on the table she
could be seeking after that as well now
according to rumors on the film at this
point Irma will have been transformed
into the island you know share in case
you don't know this ties in heavily with
the X-Men and the comics had it becoming
a sanctuary for mutants that was
overseen by Magneto I don't think he'll
be the leader of it at this point in the
MCU but the Thunderbolt will be sent
there on a quest to gain the adamantium
potentially the attempt to get it in
Captain America failed and thus the US
has to go with more unofficial routes
the Thunderbolts are basically the mcu's
answer to the suicide squad and because
of this the country has plausible
deniability when they're sent out on
jobs say the official mission fails The
Unofficial one could be launched by Val
to take the mineral under the radar Val
is the head of the CIA and she will
apparently create the Sentry to help out
with the mission however if you know the
comics then you'll know the character is
someone that can't be controlled and he
switched sides several times Well I say
sides most of the time he's just a loose
cannon that's pretty much on his own
team and though I wouldn't necessarily
say he's out for his own best interests
he's also someone who can't really be
controlled the Sentry is complex mental
health issues and these often see him
going off into an uncontrollable Ray age
where he wrecks Havoc the major issue
with Sentry is that he has never fully
mastered his abilities and thus when he
unleashes them he often loses control
and destroys things that he doesn't mean
to according to the leak's he'll
apparently turn on the Thunderbolts from
admission and they'll have to take him
out how this is done we don't know as
he's way way more powerful than they are
there are several weapons in the MCU
though that can take down a Superman
level threat you've got your Overkill
things like the ultimate nullifier or
they could just build a weakness into
the Sentry the comics have his main one
being antimatter and due to him being
able to control molecules this has a big
effect on him this isn't the only
weakness either and due to his mental
health issues he's very vulnerable to
psychic attacks potentially one of the
mutants on jenosha triggered him though
is delving way too far off in a theory
time and that's all rumors plot leaks
and general things that we've heard
about the movie it's still a while off
and all this is subject to change so
take it with a pinch of salt I'll of
course keep you updated if anything
change changes or if we hear anything
else and in the meantime I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the movie and if
you want to support the channel and
check out the link to our clothing store
in the description below we've got a
great Ant-Man Size Matters t-shirt link
there I see you Chumps one and also a
theory time one if it's not done your
head in which I apologize if it has
either way I'm gonna be nice to you and
if you drop a comment below you'll be
entered into a competition where we're
giving away Dawn of the Dead and Black
Adam to 3 subscribers on the 15th of
January all you have to do to be with a
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe the notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the leaks if you pick the
comments at random on the 15th and the
winners of the last one are on the
screen right now so that to you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out one of our
breakdowns linked on screen right now
we're doing loads at the moment bloody
loads and uh yeah go check her about
right after this if not if not well
thanks for sticking through the video I
appreciate it I'll see you in the next
one take care peace
see on the next one go back
[Music]